this is something women should know you
know if you're dating a man whose
fundamental orientation is short-term
sexual gratification he's either
pursuing a psychopathic path of
manipulation or you're training him to
become that person the amount of sexual
boredom in the society is extraordinary
so you have more sexual choice and
variety available than literally any
time in human history given free license
by the state because there are no
intermediate social institutions in
which sort of informal mechanisms of
disapproval could make themselves felt
and one of the things it turns out
psychologically that that human beings
are turned on by is taboo and so when
you get rid of literally every taboo
then people tend to get bored and the
power of what marriage was supposed to
be is it takes this this short-term
hedonic desire and it said because
female virtue still existed that in
order for you to obtain this you're
going to have to sublimate that desire
for the building of something greater